la escasez de alimentos básicos y de
gasolina por falta de conductores que
los transporten es un efecto inevitable
del break city de la pandemia del cob y
19 presionado por el pánico colectivo de
la población por falta de gasolina en
todo el país el gobierno ha tenido que
relajar temporalmente su sistema de
inmigración endurecido tras el divorcio
con la unión europea para permitir que
trabajadores especialmente conductores
de esa comunidad y de todo el mundo
puedan venir al reino unido- se anunció
que se otorgarán 5500 visas para
conductores de camiones hasta la noche
de navidad podrán tener estas visas para
evitar escasez de alimentos y de otros
bienes importantes para las fiestas de
navidad sin embargo diferentes sectores
de la industria han dicho que estas
visas 5.500 son muy pocas para el tamaño
del desafío para la cantidad de
conductores que se necesitan se prevé
que se requieren al menos 90 mil
conductores para poder aliviar esta
situación los cientos el gobierno de
boris johnson está presionado por
diferentes sectores y la población en
general para que adopte medidas urgentes